this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice my
co-host today
anthony o'neil ramsey personality number
one best-selling author as we answer
your questions about your life
and your money open phones triple eight
eight two five
five two two five so anthony i'm
wondering
if our radio audience looking deeply in
the radio can see the cabo
tan that i got from three weeks in cabo
you guys looking into your radio i'm a
little darker he is
a little better looking than i was yeah
uh and then i was from three weeks in
combo we'll just do
do you good i'm just saying you look
younger too man i'm proud of you
oh there you go there you go oh you want
a raise
[Laughter]
oh i have to get on the radio and learn
how to do this again after three weeks
it's like yeah you know
i i gotta learn how to do a lot of stuff
again yeah you know
but i'm here i've been holding it down
with you with the other personality so i
could teach you i heard like you and
deloney were big head on friday
man we had a blast you know when we got
james and kelly in there we got to be a
big hit
yeah because they're hard on you
afterwards oh yeah yeah
it's their task masters are they you
know you know there's one there's two
offices i don't want to go in i don't
want to go in your office i don't want
to go in james and kelly what's been
mean to you in my office huh
i want to be mean to you i'll do it
right here on the air oh well
anything wrong with my office oh no like
a principal's office come on man
all right folks i am happy to be back i
love doing this show i love working with
you guys and helping you
and um it has been an eventful couple of
weeks around ramsey while i've been gone
and uh uh a lot of new a lot of change
a lot of things uh different than they
were a lot of pain in the process
but uh we're here yeah and we're excited
to help you guys and serve you it's what
we do
it is a free call at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five some say the advice is
worth what you pay for it so shut up
if you don't like my advice you can cut
my pay in half triple eight eight two
five
five two two five andrew is going to
start us off in california hey andrew
how are you
dave i'm great how are you better than i
deserve sir how can i help
all right so uh i am
i'm on uh baby step seven
i'm investing now uh
21 years old i'm in the military so
living in embarrass room i have no
mortgage i have a roth ira open with
vanguard with twelve thousand dollars in
it
uh but it's in a money market accountant
has been since i
started deploying it uh what should i
invest in
okay well good good so you're in baby
step seven because you don't have a
house
right exactly okay what's in baby set
three andrew real quick
what's your fully funded emergency fund
amount
uh i i've i
just actually came back from deployment
with the uss nimitz
so i actually have uh yeah
you should have a lot i have a healthy
yeah i have a healthy
little checking account how much is in
your healthy checking account
about 34 000 and another 12 in savings
good for you well thank you for your
service sir we appreciate your service
and thank you
it's quite quite a uh an assignment
you've been given
and uh very very well done so what we
teach is to
invest in good mutual funds it's what i
have done for
40 years and what anthony does and what
all of us here do
we invest in growth stock type mutual
funds
there are four categories and we split
it evenly across those and that's what
you need to get in touch with vanguard
and move into those four or get in touch
with one of our smart vester pros
to help you with that they are not
people that work for us but they're
people that we recommend
that will do things and they will teach
you which is really important at your
stage of investing for you to start
learning
because investing can be a little bit
intimidating can't it
oh for sure i was looking at uh looking
at
my account today and i was seeing a lot
of uh
terms that i didn't really recognize
yeah
because i was i was looking at it uh one
that caught my attention was a
u.s growth stock with a 3 thousand
dollar investment minimum
uh i was thinking about going into that
one but uh
i didn't understand it so that's good
don't don't put money in something you
don't understand yeah and andrew i think
the key thing here with david saying
what i want to tell you as a young
person
too is um that i like the fact that
you're saying hey i don't understand
this
well it's very important to remember
what dave said find a financial advisor
uh and i'll say this i mean i'm not a
huge fan of you know certain people i
want you to go to one of our smart
investor pros
because they're going to spend time with
you and teach you everything you need to
know
i'm not going to speak negative about
vanguard but i'm pretty sure they're not
going to give you as much one-on-one
training as
our smart investors will and it's
important for you at your age to really
get the knowledge
while you're investing your money and so
ask the good questions
yeah the nervousness that you feel with
anything new
is wisdom like the first time you get
behind the wheel of a car you've never
driven a car it's
you're nervous the first time you do x
or why ride a bicycle whatever the
metaphor we want to use is so in fact
you don't know what you're doing is
it makes you nervous that's that's
wisdom but that that's also says you got
some learning
and the more you learn the more
comfortable you are
and it will become like driving a car
where initially you were nervous but
eventually you
develop a level of competency
and you learn the terms and you're very
comfortable with them the good news is
if you sit down with the smart investor
pro with the heart of a teacher they're
going to teach you now let's start with
that
where you were a minute ago okay a
growth
stock mutual fund now what a mutual fund
is is think about anything as mutual as
a group of people
so a mutual fund is a group of people
funded to fund
and so you put some money in i put some
money in anthony put some money in right
it's a mutual fund mutually
funded that's where it comes from okay
that's a mutual fund okay
instead of buying a single stock
whatever they invest that money that we
mutually funded
into tells us what kind of mutual fund
it is
and so if they invest that money into
bonds then it's a bond
mutual fund if they invest that money
into companies
stock ownership in that company and
these are companies that are growing
we would call those growth stocks
right and and if it's a mutual fund
it would be a growth stock mutual fund
in your case it was u.s which tells us
one more thing
where are all these companies andrew
the grand old united states of america
there you go baby
and so if it were an international fund
it would have
some it would have only funds that are
not
u.s companies that are not u.s
if it's a world fund
then it's the whole world so it's got
some u.s
some foreign in it but in your case
you're looking at american companies
only
that are growing and it's multiple
different companies 90 to 200 different
companies that'll be bought in there
and people mutually funded this fund
including you and so you own a piece of
a whole bunch of pieces of little bitty
pieces of
growth companies companies that are
growing and that will grow your money
like about 10 times as fast as a stupid
money market account you're in
so that's your first lesson dude this is
how you learn it
well done i'm proud of you and again
thank you for your service click
smartvestorpro at daveramsey.com
and we'll get you lined up
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air i am dave
ramsey
your host this is the ramsey show open
phones as we talk about your life
and your money it's a free call triple
eight eight two five
five two two five brian is in arkansas
hey brian welcome to the ramsey show how
can we help
thanks dave welcome back you were missed
and thank you for all
you and your team does well thank you
sir
yeah i am 59 years old i'm looking to
retire in six years
i have a 401k a roth and a traditional
i'm thinking about rolling my truck
doesn't make sense to roll my
traditional
into a roth i do have the cash to pay
the taxes
or should i take that cash and invest it
in real estate
hmm well neither one's a dumb thing
yeah it's just a matter of preference
which one you want to do
how much is in your roth or how much is
in your traditional that you would
convert
about 240 000 okay and so you're talking
about what a 70 000 tax bill
yes okay huh
and what other uh nest egg do you have
uh that is it uh i mean i have the cash
uh other than my house which is paid for
don't have any debt okay so here's the
thing the longer you leave that alone
after converting it to a roth the more
sense it makes for it to be converted
okay so if you convert it and start
drawing down on it almost immediately i
would be
less likely to do that if you're going
to convert it and never touch it
for 10 15 20 years because you've got
other things you're going to live on
then i'd be more likely to do that do
you own
other investment real estate no
okay and if he was to purchase real
estate uh right now brian would you uh
pay cash for it are you using that 70
grand and put down
no i would i would pay cash for it how
much cash are you sitting on
about 220 000. okay
so what what price range of real estate
are you thinking about buying
well rental property uh where i'm at is
pretty tight because the universities
around
and so they're going around 220
to 240 just depends on what kind of deal
you can get
so it'd use up most of your cash if you
did that deal
yes and if you do the if you do the 70
000 it takes you out of that market you
have to do a different kind of rental
property
or wait a little while yeah yeah what i
figured i would do if i went ahead and
rolled the traditional
into a lot but i i would then take the
remaining money and put it into
a low cost stock index fund
[Music]
until you had enough to buy a house
correct yeah what's your household
income how long is that going to be
uh let's see right right now we're we're
about
160 and that includes my wife and she's
looking to retire in two years and when
she does it'll drop mine down
he'll drop our income down to about 105
000. yeah but we're only talking about a
year to get the money back right
yeah yeah yeah so if you do if you do
the roth now buy a house a year from now
right
that's possible depends you know if real
estate keeps going up in this area like
it has been it would take it would
take it longer yeah but don't get real
estate favor to the point that you start
paying retail for stuff or you start
chasing
returns or something like that you're
gonna end up paying too much most the
best money on a real estate that you
make is when you buy it
yeah meaning you get a good deal when
you buy it yeah that's what you're
looking for and so don't
don't buy into the lie oh real estate's
hot real estate's hot
you know you can't get a good deal
there's always a deal somewhere you may
have to poke around a little bit to find
it
or you may have to put some paint on it
later if you find it or something like
that but you'll find it
and especially if you're sitting there
with cash and you're taking your time
and
uh the deals are the deals are for the
patient people they're not for the ones
that buy off on the
oh well all real estates college town's
always high so
yeah that's a um uh that says you're
gonna
pay too much you don't wanna pay too
much now when you when you uh pull it
over to a roth how long before you draw
out on it brian
oh i'm looking at six years so you're
less than 10 years before you start
drawing on it but you would just barely
start at that point
and as you had the property it would
change that as well yeah
right yeah uh well with the rental
property i could start using the
uh income from that right away and
that's one of the things i was looking
at
you know what i do i would start looking
for deals right now
and if you can lay your hands on
something go ahead and do it that's
really inexpensive
that's cheaper than you're thinking
right now and then use some of the rest
of that and move
some of the roth money now and move some
of it later if you don't find a deal
a bargain i'm talking about not just
something that's freaking for sale that
you like
yeah i'm talking about a bargain you're
looking for you want to make some of
your neighbors a little upset with you
so that means like if you're looking at
a house of 220 230 you're looking at a
house like 160 170
i'm making 180 offers on these 220s and
find somebody who's a little more
motivated to sell
even though it's a quote hot college
town
so anyway something like that then that
changes the equation yeah
if you don't find a 180 purchase on a
220
or something like that then go ahead and
make that roth move within six months
and go and make that roth move
uh and in the meantime you will have
been saving up anyway so we're only
talking about a year difference either
way but the only way i would put the
real estate ahead of the roth
even though it's only one year is uh if
you got a bargain
and so start poking around see if you
can find that deal i think he can dave
but patience
look for something with the gutter
hanging off and you can put the gutter
back up they're not that hard to put up
so
um that's the kind of thing you're
thinking of
i've owned thousands of pieces of real
estate in my life i used to flip for a
living
and i currently own several hundred
million dollars worth i love
love love real estate when i am buying
real estate i am
trying to find a deal yes sir because
the
old guy taught me when i was 20
something years old by and he said the
money is made
at the buy yeah meaning what you pay for
it
is the thing yeah money's made at the
buy it's not location location location
that establishes the value but the money
is made
at the buy so that's a good question
susan's with us susan is
in columbus ohio hi susan how are you
i'm doing well thank you how are you
better than i deserve
and that's for sure what's up thanks so
much for taking my call i have a
tax flash investing question i am very
new to investing so be patient with me
i was completing my taxes for 2020 with
turbo tax
and i got an alert that i had over
funded
my roth ira which i guess i just wasn't
paying attention
and that i needed to move those funds in
order to avoid a penalty
and i was wondering what you would
suggest i would do to correct that
before finishing my taxes
how much go ahead i'm sure i'm sorry i'm
sorry dave how much uh suzanne
it's not much it's about 600 um
so it's not like the penalty is scaring
me but i'd like to avoid it if i can and
then
correct for the future okay let's make
sure turbo tax is right because they're
not always
um so okay uh what did you put into the
roth
so i put in over 6 000 this year
i got a raise and i was doing a
percentage of my income and so this year
i put it over
i see okay and you're how old
i'm 32 okay then you're fine that that
is correct then
so any amount that you've over funded
you just have to move it into another
investment just get it out of that
account
yeah okay that's all there is no penalty
you're fine you caught it in time you're
not gonna have anything so just
you know get in touch with whoever
you're the investor wherever that
investment is and say i need to move 600
out of here it's over funded
and uh you can move it over to money
market you can move it into your
checking account whatever just get it
back out of there
reverse the process that you use to over
fund it
and um and you know then you're not
going to have any issue but you but they
are right they've given you the correct
advice
that um uh that you
you know you are limited to six thousand
dollars of earned income
and i'm assuming you had an earned
income that high so good stuff nice
thanks for the call nice i love it yeah
it's good that you're getting it done
it's good that that's uh that's going to
that level have you ever had that call
before dave i over
funded my investment accounts it usually
doesn't happen um
on an individual account what can happen
on uh sometimes you'll hear it on a 401k
if you are a highly compensated employee
yeah
uh with your company and the uh
bottom 2 80 of the company does not
participate in the 401k at a high enough
level they
limit how much you can put in oh and so
you go back down
and you can have over funded your 401k
okay
because of the highly compensated rule
that happens a lot more often
than this does because usually if you're
doing an ira it's set up on a
flat thing at 600 6 000 500 bucks a
month coming out rather than a
percentage yes
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt
free stage jeremy is with us hey jeremy
welcome to the show how are you sir
better than i deserve how are you
another day above ground so i beat the
odds anthony how are you hey i'm doing
well man i love you
bro excellent where do you live uh
village of los ranchos new mexico
it's right next to albuquerque oh
beautiful area yeah it is it's gorgeous
out there
that's fun and all the way to nashville
to do a debt-free scream
yes sir and i got paid to get here too i
drive a semi so it worked out well
i like this plan yeah yeah i ain't
playing this is a drive-by debt free
screen
parked across the street yes sir i love
it
all right how much you pay off jeremy uh
i paid off 89
941 dollars and 48 cents love it and how
long did this take
um i started my debt-free journey april
17th
of the 11th and finished up about the
11th of february
of this year so just short of four years
okay all right
very cool and your range of income
during that time
starting in 2018 it was thousand
seven hundred seventy five dollars and
currently i'm about the forty thousand
eight hundred mark
and you did ninety grand in four years
well i took you literally when you said
beans and rice
okay i kid you not it was not a metaphor
you just did it
yeah and i i realized that one day about
two months ago maybe three
that you were just kind of you know
playing it so to speak
and i just kept doing it oh well okay
and i
i i just drive i just work all the time
i love to work i love what i do
yeah um so i'm a happy boy i just wanna
keep running yeah
so what kind of debt was the 90 grand um
let's see here
the first eighty seven thousand six
hundred three dollars and 48 cents was
from
a divorce property settlement um i've
been more civilized bar fights than what
that was
[Laughter]
i'm not kidding i i kid you there's a
broken beer bottle involved
i'm just saying i wish there was it
would have been less painful
and um yeah yeah and uh then uh 2338 was
a personal loan
okay wow all right so the property
settlement is of
you know four years you've been on beans
and rice to get that in your rearview
mirror no
pun intended right yeah wow well
pretty cool yeah it's it's been quite
the experience there's there's just no
getting around it
yeah so the the pain of the divorce plus
all this man i mean
this is a real thing to be done with it
i'm going to work really hard on getting
sand in my eyes
um but yeah that's exactly right uh yeah
it's it's been an experience for sure
now this is freedom times two
or ten um well when i get to tell my
story when you're ready for me to do
that
do it okay um february of 2002 was when
my first divorce was
finalized i never thought i'd go through
a divorce let alone two of them
and um that's where this property
settlement came in it was
a thousand dollars a month for three
years spousal maintenance and then child
support
all the way until my son turned 18. and
then at the end of that
three years i was supposed to hand her a
lump sum of 36 thousand dollars
right i've never had 36 000 in my life
um and so the minute you fall into
arrears
it starts earning interest at 10 percent
and that's where the bar fight happened
um and then just over five years ago
i was head over heels in love with my
second wife came home one day and she
greeted me at the door with i'm not in
love with you anymore and i'm like
did i miss did i not get the memo um and
so
i left phoenix i was living in phoenix
at the time i called my mom i was in
tears and
you know can i come home blah blah blah
yeah so i driving home i called a friend
of mine wes
and i used to i was a bouncer for him at
a bar in tucson
and uh told him what happened and he
said jeremy drive a truck
i said what he said you'll always have
money in your pocket you'll always have
a job
and so three four months later i got my
cdl class a
and i've been driving for every five
years in july
and i've been doing flatbed for just
over two years and i love flatbed
so yeah wow if throughout those four
years
i mean you you clearly have been through
a lot
but getting out of debt what would you
say was the hardest thing
throughout that journey
i think it was there are times when the
wheels don't feel like they're catching
yeah you know it's like you're driving
in the mud and i get to do a lot of that
um and i look back at the numbers and
when i hit like
i was at 40 000 or 60 000. i was like
woohoo and
now i just you almost feel nauseous when
you think about
that number and maybe being in that kind
of dead ever again which i will never do
it will not happen but i i really feel
like that that's what
what the hardest part was but then when
you saw the traction
i mean i get paid direct deposit well my
checks would hit you know midnight on
tuesday
mondays i beg your pardon and i would
sometimes wake up at two o'clock in the
morning
and i lived off of x amount and
everything also just sliced it right off
the top and sent it in
and i would do that now who are you
sending it to your ex
or to a lawyer or the courts or the
courts the court system of arizona yes
okay
all right so they're keeping track of
this and they're
they're taking it off as it goes yeah
and that's where it went kind of
sideways a little bit towards the end
i thought i was done and then i got up i
talked to my
my friend who's an attorney and he was
telling me
he's like well no you've got this and
that i'm like what and they they're like
adding another three thousand dollars to
it it was for fees
that they didn't count up and add on
until the start of the next year kind of
thing so it was really kind of wonky
and when i was trying to make those last
payments i'll never forget i called him
and i was trying to do it over the phone
and it wouldn't accept it and i'm like
this is really weird the government is
not taking my money
and i called department of economic
security
all of them in arizona i called him 15
times that day and i called my attorney
i called my financial coach who's
endorsed by you karen pennock
and they're all double checking
everything and they said no you're
you're zeroed out
i almost went off the road i started
crying wow so yeah
i was in little rock yeah it's over yes
sir
yeah finally over yes so who introduced
you to
us um i my second wife
we had actually kind of started talking
about the program and then
there was some malfeasance on her part
um
she was a painkiller addict and for all
the time
we were together we were married for
almost 11 years
i turned a blind eye to the fact that
that's what she did
um missing money and i'd find her passed
out or
it was horrible um and i just kept going
oh it's great
so what's the future look like now uh if
it got any brighter i'd be wearing
sunglasses right now
so yes so proud of you man thank you
dave thank
done you got to feel good i do i you
there's a cleanliness to your story
that's pretty incredible
well thank you sir that's pretty cool i
mean it's a
bunch of crap and it's all behind you
yes that's that's just a cool feeling
yes yeah that's the greatest feeling for
sure yeah i'm so proud of you very much
what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of debt is i mean you went
all in
i did um you know i think that's just
really what you got to do you just got
to say what i was doing before
wasn't working um and you just got to
commit
you know it's just like you know i was
in the military and i taught karate for
20 years and if you're gonna do
something
you've got to just buckle down and get
it done yeah you know you learn to say
no to yourself and
just you know nose to the grindstone as
it were yeah
well it's certainly all in all in
well we've got a copy of our latest
best-selling book here for you know
yourself know your money by
rachel cruz that'll be your gift for the
day congratulations man thank you
so proud of you all right it's jeremy
i'm sorry dave i'm sorry i've got a list
of people to thank
okay um because otherwise i want to
better go fast yes sir uh my mom olivia
my sister deborah my son remy
my friends wes grant max rob meredith
and ray angie fernando jeff
my tim co family colt and dan cooper and
tim
uh kelly and mike my karate instructor
sean and his wife rebecca
the dave ramsey baby step community as
well i love it man they're awesome
that's a very that's a great facebook
page yes it is all right 90 000
paid off in four years jeremy did it
making
26 to 40. is all beans and rice for real
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three
[Music]
[Applause]
i like that one you know transformation
is all about new beginnings
yes sir it's all about new beginnings
yeah fresh
start yeah and if you look into his eyes
you can see he got some sand in his eyes
dude
you can see there's a little leaking
going on yeah that's a good thing it's a
fresh
start there's a cleanliness there you
can just feel it in his spirit
awesome hey guys when are you gonna do
that those of you listening right now
you've been kind of listening and not
doing this
i want you to be on here i want you to
be free man
get after it get it baby get it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
nine eight seven six
five four three
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host
today this is the ramsey show i'm your
host dave ramsey open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
terry is in jacksonville florida hi
terry how are you
okay dave i'm great thank you for asking
sure how can we help
well i'm a 73 year old um
married individual this year next month
we'll
make it 53 years wow wow
yeah yeah blessed by god beyond the
measure
um i had two
marvelous careers again directed by god
a
21-year career in the navy and then 21
20-year career in aviation uh
well wow education and uh
i i i currently own my own home
i follow i have actually followed your
advice for about 40 years
so my wife and i tried to live debt free
almost
our whole married lives but uh i i
i own my own home get free of that
but i have a rental home that my son has
been uh renting
and i purchased just recently searching
another
uh original home that he's going to be
living in
it's in a since he's in a school
district actually where i was the
principal of the school so we wanted our
granddaughter to attend that same school
so my question is the home that he's
currently living in
uh it's i owe about 91.5 on it
it's probably a sale value of about i
don't know 120 125.
i'm wondering should i just sell that
thing or should i rent it
current uh mortgage is 659 and i can
probably
rent it for 1200.
okay uh is your son paying you
market rent on the other property
uh on the the one that he's currently
living in
well the one he's moving into i guess
yeah he's going to he's going to be
paying he's going to be paying the
mortgage online why didn't he just buy a
house
he well he's got his own business and he
couldn't qualify for the home
and as you know houses down here this
the actual actual how we've been looking
in that area
like i said we wanted our granddaughter
to go to you know attend the school
and that was your principal and uh
and so uh there were hardly any houses
on the market when that one came
available it was a nice house
and actually the day it went up for sale
made an offer on it
well let's reverse let's reverse
engineer your question then
sure if you had forty thousand dollars
sitting in the middle of your kitchen
table
or thirty thousand dollars and you did
not own the property that he's moving
out of that you're asking me about
would you go buy it
um if it was if just forty thousand
dollars to do whatever it was no i'm
saying forty thousand dollars because
that's your down payment then you got a
ninety thousand dollar mortgage right
well i see what you're saying because if
you sell it it's gonna put 30 000 bucks
in the middle of your kitchen table
right but i'm gonna have to pay capital
gains on that i'm sure
yeah you know there'll be a little but
it won't be
have you been depreciating the property
yes sir
for how many years oh
about 11. yeah you'll have some capital
gains that are pretty substantial then
so um it sounded the way you worded it
it sounded like you like the property
and you think it'd be good to own it i
don't see a problem with you owning it
i do want you to go back to your
original philosophy and let's get these
properties paid off
yeah do you have any cash terry to pay
them off
i have to liquidate some mutual funds
how much do you have in mutual funds
well like if um
i've got two iras uh a mutual fund i've
got about three hundred and ten thousand
dollars
okay what other nest egg do you have
other than that um
i've got a stock in the company that the
square incorporated that i bought it
like uh nine dollars a share
the last time i looked it was like four
years here what's it worth what's your
total portfolio worth
oh probably uh not counting the house
no i'm saying that that stock what's
that stock or the value of that that
account
oh probably about uh 35 000
okay i would use that towards that
mortgage let's get that mortgage paid
off as quick as you can with that other
sixty thousand i would not liquidate
your
your mutual funds i just start doing it
out of the budget and clean it up as
fast as you can
if you're gonna keep it let's have a
plan to get paid off yeah otherwise
otherwise i'd sell it okay yeah i
uh my my thought process with keeping it
was
you know where else can i invest the
money and probably make about four
hundred dollars a loan
yeah well you're not making 400 a month
because you're going to have
expenses on that you're going to have
vacancy you don't have everything else
you're probably making 200
a month yeah um so you're not
and it could end up actually being a
cash drain as long as you leave that
stupid debt on it
so the only way i would do it if i were
in your shoes is get rid of the debts
very soon if not immediately
yep uh and i would not use your 300
grand to do that i would use the 35 000
in stock to do that so um
[Music]
i don't know yeah i'm right there with
you dave that's what i was asking
and then two i don't really like the
fact that he's renting a house out to
his son
at just mortgage in a neighborhood that
the sun can't afford to buy
exactly you know it's like that's right
that's a potential liability it's gonna
come back and bite you
exactly yeah so boy child needs to get
his own mortgage and get that thing paid
off get out of your name as soon as
possible too
yeah um and so just it's not just about
where your kid goes to school you don't
go
hundreds of thousand dollars in debt to
get a school district thank you for
saying that dave you know that's
that's that's not smart yeah well you're
going to get bit yeah
that's what's going to happen and so
we're um
and we're using the love of grand baby
to justify all this yeah
so and i love my grandbabies absolutely
absolutely that's not the issue
absolutely open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five amy is in muncie
indiana hi amy
welcome to the ramsay show hi hi thank
you how are you sure how come better
than i deserve how can we help
okay my question is my husband and i
just
opened a business together it's so far
been very successful
it's only been five weeks but we also
still have
our own business i have one he has one
my question is how do we combine
everything together and like
pay deals out of one account
so like my business i just
use it for business only and then i have
a separate checking account that i pay
for
all of our house bills he uses his
business account
for all for everything
um and then our new account
i don't think we should use it at all
because
at this point we don't even know
actually what we're making from it
all right let's try this let's try this
fine these are three separate
businesses that operate independent of
each other correct
correct okay each of those should have
their own checking account
yes and you should not do any personal
business out of those checking accounts
right
then you should have a household then
you should have a household account
that is your home account and that's
where you'd buy groceries and pay the
light bill and
eat and do all these you know save for
the kids college all these kinds of
things that you're gonna do
the profits come out of the three
checking accounts from the business
hold out some money for taxes so you
don't get bit on your uh
quarterly renew or your quarterly
estimates
and then roll the money into your
personal account both of your names
ought to be on all of these accounts
yeah
yes both of our names is on all of them
but however we're still we've only been
married a year and a half
and we we still i i don't write anything
out of his he doesn't write anything out
of mind even though our names are
on all of them we still use it like it's
separate and i think it's causing
problems yeah you need to have a plan
where you're all in agreement about
all the money yeah on the how the
businesses are run
and how much money comes out of those
businesses what expenses those
businesses are doing
and then when it comes home and it goes
into that home account you're certainly
in agreement on
everything there yeah and it sounds like
you all are still
okay separate a little bit i mean
combine the mindset this is our
businesses
as a couple as a family i mean do things
jointly
not separately yeah what happens when
i'm working with these entree leadership
guys is they'll use their business
account to buy crap that they can't get
away with if they bring the money home
[Music]
that's exactly what's going down right
here
yeah you're not going to buy that out of
the personal account so i'm just going
to sneak it out that's my
business over there yeah i don't think
so bubba
that's not how it works this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
the house is in good shape it's you know
doubled in price
we've had it for six years so if you
sold it to the tenant watch itself or if
you sell it after fix up what's yourself
for
that i just don't know yet i i'm just in
the beginning stages
of getting into this but i didn't know
what would be your guess
what makes you ask the question
get 80 maybe 200 uh if i sold it to the
tenants without doing anything
but just as is maybe maybe one six
oh so almost four years i'm sure what
would require me to to
you know fix it up to you know to that
rocks yeah we're losing you you're
cutting in and out but the
uh so if you were going to sell it as is
you'd sell it for 160 if you fixed it up
you'd sell it for 200
if you were gonna in our we're guessing
because you haven't run
all the numbers out to exact but you're
thinking you'd spend like ten thousand
dollars and do
and go over there and paint it or
something
you know yes i'm aware of you know
i'm losing you you're cutting in and out
try one more time
you know new paint is that it's hard to
say
yeah yeah you could really easily not
make
that much extra on this so i i mean
uh i don't see a problem offering it to
the new tenant but i'm going to try
the current tenant first before you just
straight up move them
um would you still offer for 160 today
no i think i would just see ask them if
they have an interest in it and then put
a price on it yeah
and let's go into it from there right
okay
yeah i mean i was going to eventually
get an appraisal on it and kind of go
from there and then
do some comparables you know with a
local provider you know and kind of see
what what
maximize it for right i didn't know
generically it's better to try to go in
and fix it up or if i would spend twenty
thousand
if i'd only get twenty thousand more
would that even be worth the time
it doesn't it doesn't sound like it is
it sounds like you're probably better to
roll it but maybe 160 over 200 is not
the actual spread
it might be 70 over 200 or whatever i
don't know let's talk to the tenant see
if we can get it moved that way
if they move out in order to get it
market ready you got to do some work for
it
that's a different story you're probably
going to have to do that to get it to
move unless you're in a white hot market
of some kind there
yeah but um i kind of like the idea
though offering it to the tenant dave
and me
me personally i would probably say hey
whatever that is i will uh give it to
them say hey listen i'll take
two percent off and cover your closing
costs to call it a deal let's do it
mm-hmm yeah get some kind of incentive
to get them in there
yeah and then you don't have to worry
about it you don't have a real estate
commission on it you don't have a lot of
stuff on it then at that point so
yeah and uh it's also a kind thing to do
is before rather than just give them
eviction notice you know it's over
uh just say you know we're moving we're
moving you out uh oh wait a minute
we're going to give you the opportunity
to buy it and if you don't want to buy
it then we move you out that has a
little different
yes slaver on the transaction yeah
especially after three years i think
they like that house
yeah that's true if they can afford to
buy it and there may be reasons that
they're
rendering you never know carlos is in
san antonio hey carlos
welcome to the ramsey show how can we
help
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve my call
yeah and anthony how you doing i'm doing
well man thanks for asking
great great hey so uh we were approached
recently my wife and i by a company that
wanted to uh
refi operate us to refire home uh right
now we're at a
3.75 apr and they're offering us
a 2.5 or fixed rate for 15 years
now here's the here's the thing they're
offering at no
no closing costs and originally when i
heard that i was
i was very you know intrigued and i
wanted to know if there's anything
that you guys have heard um if that
that's you know kind of
a common practice or or if there's
anything hidden that should be looking
out for
is this an fha loan no
yeah 15-year fix well that's a great
deal
yeah um so i don't know what they're how
they're doing this where they're picking
up the closing costs because somebody's
going to pay the closing costs somewhere
are there any fees i know some people
will leave with no closing costs but
they're there because there's a bunch of
points involved or something yeah
i i don't know i mean at first i was
very uh you know it sounded kind of like
busy but i mean i was there
there's no closing costs and then why
not right
how long have you been in the house
carlos uh five years
okay are you gonna be there a while yes
sir yeah let's just run the deal to
ground and figure out what's wrong with
it because it smells bad
yeah let's find let's find out why you
know how is it you're offering a two and
a half percent rate which is basically a
street rate
with closing costs only they're going to
have no closing costs where are you
picking up the closing costs i want to
know where that's coming from
how it's being covered um and if you
keep getting a bad feeling off of it
just run just because of the bad feeling
yeah but i don't mind running at the
ground asking some questions you may
learn something
you can also call churchill mortgage the
folks that we've endorsed for 20 plus
years here on the air
and they can walk you through exactly
what they can do and that'll give you a
comparison
yeah in the situation but i'm not aware
of rates being low enough that a two and
a half percent rate would warrant a free
closing cost that doesn't make sense
now fha has a streamlined product but it
would be a little bit above market
and your the closing costs are just
eating up in the higher rate is where it
amounts to
because it's slightly above market and
you can just refile your
um just the stroke of a pen you can
refine fha but that's not true on a
fannie mae
so i i guess i'll dig into it and learn
try to figure out what they're doing and
what the angle on it is
it's always good to get new information
absolutely that sounds a little
interesting to me i'm thinking dave like
you could get a two and a half or
fifteen
i'm with you let's do it let's do it but
uh i also want to make sure i don't get
the closing table and have some kind of
problem right
yeah or have signed into something i
didn't realize i was signing into or
whatever
make sure you know the whole whole
picture that's a big deal it's a good
savings so a whole percent down
yeah this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best deal
today's question comes from spencer in
utah i'm a prospective law student and i
am torn between two schools
one is more well known but is also more
expensive the other is less
recognizable but they have offered me a
full tuition scholarship does the name
of the school help significantly
and prove to be the uh
investment that college admins tout
to be uh no no no uh absolutely not
listen you guys um i went into my
doctor's office actually just the other
week dave
and for the first time in probably 36
years of me living i
asked them what school they go to and
when uh
my doctor said to school i said hey does
it matter like if if a kid came in here
today and said hey does going to this
school over
that school is that better the doctor
said no he said what makes a doctor is
is is the doctor willing to learn why
he's in school is he willing to submit
himself to other doctors to learn even
more
so my continual life of learning exactly
and growing and growing and the same is
true of law school
yes yes so that's so can you pass the
bar
okay after you graduate yep did you get
enough knowledge to pass the bar
and do you have enough knowledge to
function as an attorney
that's it and if you have that in 99
of the cases where you went to school
doesn't matter i have
10 attorneys or so in my life sadly
yeah and i can't tell you where a single
one of them went to school
you didn't ask at all no you know we
have trademark attorneys we have estate
planning attorneys we have tax attorneys
uh we have um staff attorneys
folks on team here actually i was
interviewing them so i do find out where
they're going to school for i
hire them yeah but i didn't hire them
because of where they went to school
yeah to be the ramsey solutions you know
uh
chief counsel and so forth uh and so you
know
real estate attorneys don't know where
they went to school yep so it just you
know now
there's a handful of uh prestigious jobs
that are high-end corporate things or
high-end law firms
that care tremendously about where you
went to school but it's only because of
the prestige
yes and so uh you can go to law school
free
spencer go free go free yeah 100
absolutely shane is with us in new york
city
with a similar question hey shane how
are you
hey how you guys doing today great good
how can we help
all right
okay you're going to speak directly into
your phone it's muffled oh sorry about
that is it better now yes sir thank you
all right so last year i was going to a
university
which my parents took out a loan for
about
a little period plus months i took it
out for about
22 000 and
i made a decision to change your schools
to a
cheaper school and i was making the
payments myself
to that school because i did not want to
go into debt
unfortunately my job had a little issue
and i'm out of the job for about two
months now but i'm coming back next
month
so in order to cover the rest of the
year i ended up taking out a loan to
cover the rest of the school year for
5500 um
that's that was the one i took out and
um the thing is though is that
personally speaking i would not even go
to school i have very traditional
parents who say i must go to school as
long as i live under their household
that type of rule and um only because
i'm not sure what i really want to do
yet like so
i don't see the point of spending money
to do something i don't even know what i
want to do yet
what are you studying um finance
and you're in your second year uh yes
okay and now you're at a less expensive
school in the first year
yes okay and you're how old
i'm 19. okay and you're saying that you
don't know if
you want to do this if you want to be in
the finance world when you graduate
yes because my heart has been set out
for
real estate for the past three years
okay but my parents
uh again under their household they want
me to do
something that they can go to a school
and have
a basic payload and um
so and i know for the fact you don't
really need a degree to
real estate that you have like um they
want me to get a finance degree or
community degree one of the two
so respectfully saying i do not believe
it is um right for the parent to tell
their son or daughter their child
what to do with their life
i don't see there's a problem with your
parents saying hey if you look
live underneath this house you have to
abide by these rules that's respectful
that's their house
but i think right now you have to make a
decision for yourself
what do you want to do at the age that
you're at um if you're saying hey
i want to be in real estate um i've
never done real estate dave can speak
into that
but i know it's a wow before you
generate any income i do believe some
form of education is important
uh for whatever you're going to do but i
think
right now especially taking out money no
you need to stop that process
but you do need to be working if you're
going to quit college but i think most
importantly man
you need to spend some time and identify
what it is that you really want to do
not just real estate
but even long term if that is real
estate for the next 20 30 years
okay cool but i think you need to go out
there and experience life a little bit
maybe get you a solid job that can
provide that you can move into your own
apartment maybe some roommates spend a
year to just dip and dab out there and
different things
once you identify what that is then what
our career
expert here ken coleman says then figure
out what does it take to get to that
but right now i i i would say
um pause because if you're saying you're
going to school and you're borrowing
money you're paying for something
that you really don't even really want
to do pause
but then when you pause you got to have
a game plan because now your parents
won't allow you to stay there
yeah for sure um how would you say you
are oh
i'm 19 okay well here's something to
consider
how many 35 45
and 55 year olds buy a house from a 19
year old real estate agent
that's going to be a hard road yeah it
can be done
i actually did it but it was a hard road
i mean i had my magnum pi mustache and
my disco suit on and i'm out there
trying to sell houses at 18 years old
19 years old i sold a few but it's just
because i worked my
butt off and uh and i was bold and
everything else but i it's a
very difficult uh trek to start
residential real estate at 19 years old
it can be done i'm not saying
it's impossible but i do want you to
know that that's
a little different than you rolling in
there 29.
in terms of credibility and who you're
dealing with and and how you get started
and all that so
um what i would think is that maybe we
uh
address a couple of other things and
let's take a step back
i'm not disagreeing with anthony i'm
adding to it
uh number one we're both saying no more
debt yeah
okay for school that's silly but this
school that you're in now is affordable
you just got to get six jobs and be able
to pay your way through
that's what it amounts to and so that's
just
what's necessary the um
uh uh you know and so you're gonna pay
your way through now that's step one
then step two is do you want to continue
to study finance
uh i got a degree in finance with a
specialization in real estate that was
what my degree was in
and that's how i end up you know someday
a thousand years later sitting here
but uh uh and it did it served me well
the academic
uh you know the underpinning of learning
statistics learning marketing
learning accounting the things you learn
to do finance are
those are good classes that are very
usable
in almost any business situation and so
uh whether you're the owner of a small
business whether you're in real estate
uh whether you own a company that does x
y or z or whether you
um go to work for somebody that in
almost any industry they're gonna need
people that know those things
so i i don't mind you continuing with
the finance degree as long as you pay
cash for it
or switching degree fields and pay cash
and stay at home and but you're going to
get six jobs to do that
and you're going to rethink this right
now you just feel like you're being
pushed around by everybody involved
and you're just being you know this is
feels random and you need to get the
randomness out of it absolutely
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free
stage rachel's with us hey rachel hi how
are you
better than i deserve welcome good to
have you thanks
so how much do you pay off i paid off
myself
um about 29 000 good for you where are
you from where do you live from colorado
springs colorado oh fun
well cool and how long it takes you to
pay off 29 thousand it took me about a
year
but i have to tell you before that um i
was married and we had 96 000
in debt and we paid that off in a not
off we paid most of it off all but the
29 000
in two and a half years okay and then
the divorce happened and then the rest i
paid off myself
oh okay ouch all right so your range of
income during this 12 months when you
paid off the 29 000 was what
55 to 62. okay cool what do you do for a
living
i'm an accountant all right fine how
long were you married
um 10 years okay so um
not only you got the heartbreak you got
30 000 worth of debt to deal with huh
yeah yeah he he walked away debt-free
but i
i was stuck with my student loans oh
they were student loans okay
so sally may never goes away until you
evict her
that's right the moral story is the
woman is persistent
she is a problem child unbelievable well
congratulations thank you so what made
you decide to tear into this
like this and get this paid off well
three and a half years ago my brother
who's here
and his uh wife jessica matt and jessica
gave me
your book the total money makeover i
read it in about two days
and told my husband we've gotta we've
gotta do this
and you start working on it together but
the marriage failed for other reasons
apparently exactly
okay well i'm so sorry you've been
through all that oh it's okay
it's no fun at all but you're free
exactly
marriage free and debt-free that's right
it's good
wow congratulations how does it feel
it feels amazing i hear my friends talk
about
credit cards and um it's like i forgot
what those were
yeah i love it i love it now i know
one year uh but was there anything major
uh
any difficult that last year paying off
this 29 thousand dollars
um it was actually almost easier to do
it myself
i thought so yeah i was about to say it
seemed like the hard part was with your
ex-husband okay yeah that's good that's
good so what's next i gotta ask i mean
you're debt-free
no no marriage i mean hopefully you know
we got a better husband coming down the
road but
anything else um i i wanted to tell you
that i was so
confident and um confident in myself
when i got this done the first thing i
bought was swimming lessons for myself i
never learned how to swim
i've been deathly afraid of water my
whole life wow and i learned after my
second lesson and i don't know that
confidence just kind of went
to that yeah a whole new you here yeah
so how old are you i'm 36 and taking on
new adventures like
swimming that's pretty impressive
because i i grew up in the water so
my but i've been but i've had people on
our boat and things that
were you know they would get in the
water and they were absolutely
terrified
but he got he got over it and he learned
to water skate
we taught him to ski yeah and those uh
those floaties look real good on his arm
they really do
i have no shame in my game you know i'm
scared of snakes out there in the lake
yeah we told him all kind of legends
about snakes and he really had trouble
oh yeah
well congratulations you have gone
through a lot kiddo and you've turned
your life
man upside down and straightened it out
yeah well transformation big time
so proud of you what do you tell people
the key to getting out of that is i
i think people need to find their
motivation what motivates them
um for me um there was a point and
actually anthony i met you at a
conference you did i did and i told you
i was getting divorced
i was losing my job my job was being
outsourced
i had to refinance my house i didn't
know if i'd be able to stay in my house
on my income
but your conference showed up on
facebook i
went with my sister-in-law and
we went to the conference and i think
that kind of fired me up and i was ready
to
to continue once the divorce was final i
unpaused everything and i
i went took off and go get that fresh
start and go
i'm so proud of you very very very well
done
excellent excellent job it's impressive
very impressive
29 000 in one year and learn to swim and
learn to swim
teach me some lessons next time that's a
big question
all right well we've got a copy of
rachel cruz's num our best selling our
latest best-selling book with her
which is called know yourself know your
money and uh we appreciate you coming
by and doing this and and
congratulations thank you so proud of
you i know your family's proud of you
that's why they came along to support
all good showing up very good stuff all
right
it is rachel and 29 000
paid off in 12 months making 55-62
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
one two three we're debt-free
well done very well done
yes you know it is interesting that um
that as you learn you when you start
controlling sections of your life
it gives you incredible confidence to
control other sections of your life and
to try things yeah yeah
and then at 36 years old with a
terrified of water you can learn to swim
yeah that is the first time i've heard
that particular story tied to being
was that was that a unique story for
y'all you're 25 years the idea that
people do something new
because they have confidence or they are
able to do things with their newfound
discipline
yes a lot of people lose weight yes at
the same time they're getting out of
debt it's not because they're starving
to death it's because they're
they're they're no discipline of getting
out of debt they're disappointed i'm
going to control this area of my life
well i can control this area of my life
i can control that area in my life yeah
and so lots of marriages are transformed
lots of uh
people take on start new businesses all
kinds of new things
happen once you start getting the
confidence from that discipline yes
it's very powerful stuff very well done
very well done
well a recent survey said that over 64
of americans changed their spending
habits in 2020 well i guess
64 where were the rest of them everybody
changed their spending habits in 2020
one way or another
you know if you plan to have a pandemic
proof budget
you can protect from another year of
impulse buying
and spending more than you make reset
your money habits by
getting the ramsey proven easy to use
cash management systems we've got the
starter envelope system for a limited
time
you can get the famous starter envelopes
for only
system for only five dollars
if you're constantly going overboard on
a certain category you cannot beat this
five bucks go to daveramsey.com
backslash store and you can see those
there for five
dollars you'll also see anthony o'neil's
book debt free degree which is number
one best-selling
our number one best-selling book as well
national bestseller on how to go to
college and not
have any debt
which is doable it's definitely doable
dave i read an article this morning
uh and it said that three percent of
people in the ages of 60 to 67 who are
retired
are living their dreams that the other
97
percent are not uh
that once you retire only three percent
of the people
are actually living their dreams and the
article went on to say the other six
the other 97 is because of debt
you know meaning they're fine they're
able to financially yeah
they're financially some people call
that financial independence i don't
think you ever really get
independent you're always going to be
interdependent with other people that's
the way life is designed to be that's a
good thing so i never liked that phrase
much
but the idea that i've got enough money
that i want to worry right
and i've gotta you know i can i can pay
the lights i can pay the stupid property
taxes right i can put food on the table
we can do some travel exactly i can you
know get a new pair of blue jeans
live in peace and put gas in a car yeah
you know uh that kind of stuff that
makes a difference and so
and that's what you're looking for is
the ability you're prosperous when you
have the money to do god's will in your
life yes sir
which begins with taking care of the
basic necessities certainly and you have
to worry but yeah you're right
97 of people still have worries still
major worries one of them are
and i was shot about 13 of them are
still worried about their student loans
i'm like in the 60s
oh that that was that was scary that's
sobering yes they need to stop making
these student loans
they need to stop it well you know you
know you need to let your congressman
know
stop it stop it stop it it's out of
control
especially at that age well i mean
period yeah you just need to stop it
no one goes that's a blessing you know
it's just
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
i'm dave ramsey
i've heard countless stories from people
who've lost a loved one
and then were totally shocked
by their will your final wishes
should not be a surprise people when you
leave your family in the dark you're
setting them up for huge
problems talk to them about your will
talk about your end of life plans
in the how to talk about your legacy
guide
will help you have the right
conversations before
and after making a will this guide will
teach you how to plan your conversations
get on the same page with your spouse
ask people to be your executor your
kid's guardian your power of attorney
tell the rest of the family what's in
the will this is a
free guide how to talk about your legacy
the how to talk about your legacy guide
completely free if you want it text the
word
legacy to 33 789
text legacy two three three
seven eight nine cara is in
providence rhode island hi kara how are
you
hi dave and anthony i'm doing well how
are you better than i deserve how can we
help
so two aside uh first aside is
we have made literally every financial
mistake you have ever
told anyone not to do and
me too and the second aside is
over the last few years i have checked
your book
out of the library probably at least 10
times
um 2020 came i started going back to
church i
checked your book out of the library at
the end of the year and you know what i
we got through baby step one we're on
baby step two but here it is
we are two working parents
work out of the house i work monday
through friday you know nine to five my
husband works
as many saturdays but monday through
friday and as many saturdays
and we've got two little kids they are
in
daycare and we have
aside from our not including our actual
mortgage we have a hundred and forty
thousand dollars worth of debt
and i am tracking every penny
um i have adjusted our grocery budget
unfortunately our kids have to be in
that sub par day care situations
uh because we just can't afford for them
to be in a
you know a better situation what's your
household income
i bring in about 40 and he brings in
about 60 sometimes a little more he
works in construction i work in
ironically banking
and what is the nature of the forty
thousand dollars worth of debt
oh like i said it's everything it's
student loans it's
uh consolidated credit cards
it's a a fleece that was turned into a
car loan because i did the math out and
we just didn't have any other way to go
at that point in time
you know it's it's the pmi
for our home if it's just a
conglomeration of
all of the stuff you're not supposed to
do your pmi is in
140. yeah because that's it's
it's well it's it's you know it was uh
no excuse the answer it was the
first the 20 damn so i don't consider
that
our mortgage our mortgage is 233 and
that uh
first that one uh the 20 percent down
wasn't is part of an fha loan we could
borrow both
nothing down so that 8 000 is in that
does that make sense yeah yeah so how
much do you own your car because
otherwise
um i owe 19 even though it's worth 12
and then his truck is 4 000.
so we're doing the debt snowball where i
i mean we're stacking everything we can
um i used all of our tax return
all of the stimulus money went to debt
so that was a nice you know five
thousand dollars we could throw but
basically we're probably looking at like
i don't know seven to ten years left of
at least just getting this stuff down
and
i'm just wondering like this is gonna be
a long game i know it is but i'm
we're dedicated to it we're doing what
we can i just you know
words of advice anything you might
suggest i
my dad said that he has an idea of
as far as like the leaf or the 19 owed
on the 12
worth he said i could probably
get like a a loan for a smaller rate pay
that off and then
because i need a vehicle we both work
and
i i pick up our kids and bring them to
daycare like we both need vehicles
um he said you know maybe
get something a loan at a lower rate pay
off the the vehicle
sell it and get something cheaper i'm
just
there's so many things that i'm trying
to do and we're literally i'm throwing
every
like extra five bucks i can at our debt
and
we're we're going but it's i just you
know
i respect your eyes so much um
we have been together for six years
we've been officially married for
a year um we couldn't afford to even
have like a nice wedding
but you know what so you've been dying
you've been doing stop stop stop stop
stop okay
i've done a lot of stupid stuff with my
money you said you said you opened the
conversation said you've done every dumb
thing right
and so you've done six years worth of
mistakes
you've been working on you've been
working on turning this ship around
for a month and a half two months
up until this calendar year you didn't
really work on it
you read out the book but you weren't
really doing anything
you've gotten serious in the last 30 to
60 days
yeah now i'm feeling just completely
overwhelmed yeah it's not going to take
as long as you think it's going to take
okay you just it takes a little while to
get started number one
and then number two you're going to get
some momentum
uh but it's six years worth of mistakes
they're not going to go away in six
months
no i know that i know but it's not 10
years either it's 140
000 that's 14 000 a year
that you're gonna pay off in debt making
a hundred thousand that's absurd of
course you're not going to do that
and so 30 30 000 a year in debt
reduction
would get you out in five years and
you're going to do more than that
but you just haven't found it all yet
and you because you're just getting
started
and uh you're just you know but but i
don't know what math you're running but
you're not going to pay fourteen
thousand dollars you're making a hundred
thousand
you're going to do a lot more than that
yeah well my concern is
our mortgage is 16 40. a day care is
anywhere from 14 to 1800 dollars a month
i don't know plus all of our other debts
so it's just like i said i'm literally
i i run your mortgage is 18 000 yeah
a year out of a hundred thousand how big
how big a tax refund is
how big a tax refund did you get um i
got
i got about uh i think it was just under
three thousand
we
that's 250 a month too much coming out
of your check
have you adjusted your w-2s yet
i i don't think no i i he has not yet no
i i know he hasn't okay somebody needs
somebody needs to adjust your w-2
yeah but both of you together or
whatever by about 250
a month that's going to help a little
getting rid of your car is going to help
a little
and somebody's getting you into a
hooptie and somebody's going to extra
job dave yeah and he's going to be
working
he works construction that's good news
he knows how to fix stuff and so he's
going to be fixing stuff a bunch on the
weekends
yeah yeah all the time you guys are
going to be working 80 hours a week
absolutely
it's time it's time you guys have been a
slave
to this stuff long enough you're gonna
have to rise up and bust it in the nose
and you're you've just begun i i know
you can do it
i've seen people exactly where you are
do this yes many many
thousands of times over the decades i've
been doing this
but what i do know is is the your your
sense of being overwhelmed your sense of
being stuck that your sense of
this is going to take forever comes from
the fact that the math does not lay out
perfectly in front of you right now to
where you can see everything easily
and if you're not careful you're going
to say well it's not i just can't do
this
yeah and you're going to walk away you
can do this but you're going to have to
continue to fight
scratch claw do anything you can do to
get your income up and you're out go
down
and you're going to sell stuff sell some
stuff the kids think they're next
there's a whole
bunch of stuff that you've got to do a
whole bunch of moves you've got to make
and stop coming up with excuses start
coming up with solutions
sit down with your husband say all right
babe we have five years to make this
happen
what do we need to do to make that
happen within the next five years yeah
we're gonna help you i'm gonna put you
through ramsey plus i'll put you through
financial peace university put you in
the premium version of every
dollar i'm going to pay for it for a
year you and your husband get in front
of those videos
get in those communities talk to those
coaches
those folks our team will walk with you
we will show you how to do this you can
do this
but it's gonna be very hard it's gonna
be worth it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsay show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice anthony
o'neil ramsey personality is my co-host
today
thank you for joining us america open
phones here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five don's
with us in lexington kentucky hey don
welcome to the ramsey show hey mr dave
mr anthony how are you
how are you doing today better than i
deserve how can we help
me as well uh mr dave i've got a
question
uh i'm 63 years old i've got
uh about a 360 dollars
and i had it an annuity uh
that i was i don't know i wasn't told
the truth about this annuity and i found
out about a year and a half ago
and uh so it kind of upset me and
i was aggravated with this guy and so i
just got out
i rolled the money over into an ira and
uh
finally finally i found the bank that
would give me 3.15
interest on that money locked for five
years
and that's what i've done with it
because i don't know a whole lot about
investing
and uh i was wondering what your thought
process
or thought on that is could that money
be making me more than
i mean is that a good thing that i've
got it where i've got it
locked at 3.15 or should i
think now differently about going into
mutual funds or
things like that well the good news is
you got into something that is
predictable
and that you completely understand and
have peace with
right that's good news and that's all
that that part of your move is a good
move
uh could you have done better yeah you
probably could do better
um i don't have my money tied up that
way and i'm not some kind of genius i
just
uh so so what i would tell you to do is
to begin
meeting with one of our smart vester
pros and learning
about mutual funds my personal i'm 60 so
we're very similar in age my personal
401k
iras and that kind of stuff are invested
in mutual funds
they're invested across four types
growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international now
what you want to do
is learn from and i had a similar error
a similar
uh experience to what you had but mine
was
uh 40 years ago uh to getting in with
with
a guy and what i learned from that is um
that it is my job to understand it or
not move the money
you don't count on the guy you count on
you you're the guy
yeah so you spend time with the
smartvestor pro learning
about these mutual funds how they work
what the history on them is uh and
therefore you can kind of say well i
kind of think based on that history
that gives me comfort to move some of
this 360 000 over there and you can do
an ira rollover and not have any taxes
involved
when you're ready to do it there is no
rush
right but let's just pretend that you
make
10 on 30 360 000. that's 30
36 000 or you make 5
that's 18 000. so we're having a 20 000
a year discussion
roughly two thousand dollar a month
discussion here
right all right that's worth doing a
little research over
absolutely absolutely well i'm kind of
like you i like bricks and mortar
and real estate and um i've got i've
found
uh quite a bit of real estate uh
apartment buildings
and uh i don't know i've always thought
about having plan a b and c
yeah and uh i've had those probably for
30 years
they're paid for i'm completely out of
debt i've probably got
i've got a nice real nice 260
65 000 home that's bought and paid for
so you're easily a millionaire
yes uh well done and and uh
you know i'm retired uh with 30 years of
retirement
and uh i've pretty much done what you've
what you talk about
my whole life just old school saving and
yeah staying out of debt and paying my
way as i go yeah
well what i'm doing what i'm prescribing
here is nothing really fancy
uh it's just that it's new in your
situation and so
if i'm you i'm thinking i might be
losing twenty thousand dollars a year
based on what dave's saying
so i should investigate moving this
sometime
in the next 12 months and just go on a
journey of learning
uh and don't go over there meet with
some guy and move the money the first
day
yeah absolutely i don't know that's
probably what i've done too soon when i
started out on the first in annuity
yeah and i found out eight years later
that it was uh
just a horrible thing and uh so
i just pulled it and put it in at 3.15
because i didn't know what i was doing
and
i'm like you i i believe and if you
don't know what you're doing do nothing
yeah
yeah so uh anyway uh good information
and hit smartvestorpro at daveramsey.com
it'll drop down a box
you can pick the one in your area that
you like they don't work for us
we do endorse them and one of the ways
that
one of the things they have to do to get
our endorsement is they have to have
that heart of a teacher
and so they're not going to mind sitting
with you and they're not going to
pressure you
and if you feel skunky with them or if
you feel a little slimy get out of there
you shouldn't uh we've added them pretty
heavily but
uh you know you need to be comfortable
and you know you've been burnt once and
so
it's okay to go in there with your
shields up and i'm not moving a dime
until i
understand it yes absolutely and you
know anthony that's the thing
or something um
with something we're not comfortable
with or we don't know about it's it
we all want someone else to take care of
it
we sure do that that's a comfortable
thing we're not willing to be
uncomfortable to
uh to grow yeah and i'm just thinking
about areas in my life that are that way
i mean i think about you know i don't
understand
this so would you just take care of it
for me no and you know and uh
i'll give you an example that freaking
taxes it's right now it's tax time so
i've got this
massive constant meetings just trying to
get the
dadgum iris settled and all this stuff
and get them all
lined up and this this thing the size of
a phone book that we end up filing and
all this stuff
and uh and i i hate it
yeah because it makes me mad yeah how
much i pay in taxes
uh it's my money i earned it it feels
like theft
and so i'm mad the whole time and on top
of that it's intimidating it's crud
it is and so i have to force myself
to meet with these guys who are so smart
and say okay i don't understand
and do you ask a lot of questions god
yes they hate me
do you leave feeling more knowledgeable
though yeah yeah because i'm not going
to sign it until i at least understand
the basics yes sir
because guess who the irs is going to
come knock on the door you not the guy
right they're gonna come see old dave
yep you know so i want to know enough
now
do i go through do i understand every
little thing no but
i mean here's the big thing tell me how
that worked what is this
how's that work i don't understand and
then next year they have to tell me
again
because i don't always keep it you know
i only store that information with my
brain
but that's a similar thing for me just
being
uh transparent yeah that uh
i hate it i'm mad about it i don't want
to do it
yeah but it's my responsibility and if i
don't
take the responsibility and learn enough
about it i get burned but a good thing
about it oh dave is you have
tax people in your corner who are
willing to teach you along the process
yeah
and it can't be my financial anything
unless you have the heart of a teacher
yeah
and so bless his heart he earns his
money you know
especially with dave ramsey man hard
thing
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsay show in
the lobby of ramsey solutions
julie dropped by from kansas city with a
question hey julie
what's up hi um thank you for having me
i have two children
a son that's 28 and a daughter that's 19
and with your guidance i'm gonna have
them graduating debt free from college
in just a couple short years
so thank you for that my son has cystic
fibrosis
he's 28 and cystic fibrosis is a
terminal disease which makes him
uninsurable sure so he's healthy and
he's working now in his career
but he has is married and has a
one-year-old son
so my question is i will be self-insured
in about five
years and so my question is would i
continue with my
life insurance in order to help support
his medical needs later in his life that
we're expecting
for his bills you're self-insured
so what will your net worth be well
currently
it's about 500 000 and i'm at 53.
so i'm expecting hopefully to be a
millionaire by then
yeah and or a little more and i do have
him
i've educated him on your system and
he's following it fairly well
he has a house now um and he's working
towards
his own goals so i'm more concerned
about the health concerns the medical
bills later
on as he ages
well i i no i would not get additional
life insurance on you
to take care of his medical bills were
you to pass
you've got a good net worth what i would
do is consider allocating
a larger portion of your estate to him
rather than the other child okay and
i've actually already got my will
established
i've talked to them both and i have 45
to both of them and then
with the additional 10 percent allocated
to specifically
uh trust fund for his medical that's
under his wife's name there you go
okay and that should take care of him
right i i believe it well you've already
done that
i've already done that yes so how is he
not taken care of if you pass away then
well i just i wanted to ask the question
i was here and i've been wanting to ask
the questions
i'm not being combative i'm just i'm
just wondering it sounds like you've
done it
wait great job i mean yeah yeah you did
you you're
like eight steps ahead of me you've
already executed what i dreamed up
that's excellent so
yeah yeah that's um you know all you did
was uh
you know say we're going to allocate 10
of my net worth
additional to take care of the medical
bills and you've done some calculations
that give you an estimate that thinks
that that's pretty
that's going to take care of it i don't
know why you would need more it sounds
like you did your
job touchdown okay and then some awesome
you've done a wonderful wonderful job
what do you do for a living
i'm currently a staff accountant i also
have a second job at
home depot for to help pay off my house
i've just finished my call
my daughter's college fund just the
other day she's a sophomore in college
and she has a scholarship and with her
dad's help and my help and planning then
we have her
set on a path yeah and also i wanted to
kind of
let you know that um she told me one day
she says you know
dave's like my stepdad
so the evil stepped down
he had evil in there yeah
[Laughter]
that's fun well way to go very very well
done i mean you you've
worked this thing all the way through
everybody's got a game plan
very very well executed you're a rock
star i'm so proud of you
well thank you i appreciate that and
appreciate the the confidence i just
wanted to
have that answer i thought i did but i
think you've already covered him yeah i
think he's done
okay thank you so much thanks for coming
by wow that's powerful that's very
powerful she already had it in place
yeah i mean that's amazing now those of
you that have a
special needs child often ask us about a
special needs
trust the only difference in that
and minor children for minor children
their special needs
or children that are of adult age
the only difference is like when my kids
were little we had a family trust that
would have been formed upon
our death to take care of them until
they reach adulthood
and then the money would be handed over
to them the only difference in that a
special needs trust with your will
is the money goes into the special needs
trust and
it takes care of the special needs
person out of the income created
for the rest of their lives okay instead
of just until they're 18 or 21 and then
the money's turned over to them
it's never turned over to him there's an
income created for life
yes uh it's like uh in a sense that you
would
uh in a college or university situation
they call it an endowment
where you give enough money that each
year it creates a scholarship off of the
income
yeah that the money creates and that's
in a sense what you're doing and you
fund that special needs trust with
assets or
until you've got assets you fund it with
some good term life insurance
but like in in julie's case she's built
up enough assets already to fund the
estate plan
exactly and so this is a similar
situation
uh except cystic fibrosis is not special
needs it's just a
medical condition with a tough prognosis
so um but that's uh
you know she's done a wonderful job of
thinking through it planning through it
very courageous in the way she's
addressed this very well done
yeah good job well here at ramsey
solutions we want to transform
so many lives that disruption spreads
like wildfire
across our country not only in financial
but also in mental health and marriage
and career
in leadership imagine a world where it's
weird to have a student loan
imagine a world where the majority of
people pay cash for their cars
where the credit card is the cigarette
of the financial world
used to be cool but not anymore baby
where working a job you love
and getting paid more than you've ever
been paid in your life because of king
coleman
is normal where
your relationships and your boundaries
are functioning the way they're supposed
to because of dr john delaney and so on
certainly going to school debt-free or
paying off your your student loans and
and getting rid of sallie mae because of
anthony o'neil yeah
imagine being part of causing that level
of disruption
through the whole country with the work
that you're doing every day that's why
we have a thousand people here at our
company
we're creating digital products services
we help transform people's lives
with the goal of disrupting the toxic
culture
in america and you have to admit america
needs ish as issues
if you want to join us on this crusade
we're currently on the hunt for software
engineers
ruby on rails java c-sharp front-end
technologies
if you're a ux designer seo content
marketing specialist a creative
great in sales or admin we've got about
300 positions we're going to fill
in this calendar year so to find out
about our available jobs we won best
place to work according to inc magazine
last year
text work that matters to 33789
or click the dave's hiring tab on the
front page
of daveramsey.com text work
that matters to 33789 you can get a full
list
of everything that's going on there
good stuff good times claudia is in
dallas hey claudia welcome to the ramsey
show
hi thanks for having me dave hello a.o
hope you guys join well
great how can we help so i'm a single
mom
recently divorced with two two wonderful
children
um we have really worked our butts off
this last
year to get out of the divorce debt
and uh through step four in a year wow
yeah it has been a it's been a fight
but the kids have been on board and
we've had excellent support
and so we're actually setting up their
529s this week
so we'll be through step five this week
i'm really grateful really excited
cool um so we were
you know we had in our and our goal um
really excited about getting our dream
home who's weak
you got divorced who's we oh i mean the
kids and i
oh okay you're sending them off to the
salt mines every day get some
get some work out of that okay
okay there we go that's her contribution
all right
yeah um we had our had our dream home in
mind and so we've been
you know focused on that we found a home
that we like
it's within our budget um i've signed
the contract done the inspection and
appraisal and everything is looking good
so far
but it's not our kind of dream home
and i'm thinking that if we wait and you
know
just keep shutting along at this and
save for another year
we could have that dream home and i'm
wondering if you were me
would you i would wait if you can do it
if you're going to get a better place in
one year yep i'd put it off one year
absolutely
no questions asked wait
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anthony o'neil ramsey personality is my
co-host
today john and ashley are
on the phone if i can figure out how to
do it there it is john and ashley are on
the phone in grand rapids
michigan to tell us about their
debt-free journey hey guys how are you
hey dave hey dave how you doing better
than i deserve how much of you guys paid
off
we did 63 000 in 30 months good for you
wow excellent a lot of money over 2 000
bucks a month for two and a half years
what was your range of income during
that time we started out just over 90
and then ended at 105. take home
excellent
way to go you guys yeah phenomenal job
what kind of below what kind of
crinkly envelopes in our pocket
what kind of debt was the 63 000
uh we were pretty normal so we had a
401k loan
unfortunately and then we had credit
cards we had
student loans we had an instrument we
had car
debt medical bills you name it yeah you
were like normal people very normal
people
so what happened two and a half years
ago what was the wake-up call
well we we had our group so we have uh
two
older kids we have a 15 and a 17 year
old and then my wife and i had twins
and about two and a half years ago we
were we were putting them in daycare and
we were starting to really get a little
tight overall on our budget and um
we had more money or excuse me we had
more month than money
and so we sat down and we looked at each
other and ashley said to me
what would happen if your student loan
didn't exist and we could use that money
to pay bills well
we hadn't done your plan yet and i said
you know there's a guy
i know who talks just like you were
talking to me and
my light bulb went off and so i took out
the i had an old
financial piece book and i said hey
let's let's start this program and and
the rest is history
wow wow long history yeah well went back
and forth
dave definitely we had to get on board
to do this
because it that's all it took it had to
be a team effort so we had
saturday morning finance meetings that
we
argued over we put up an excel
spreadsheet on the tv
our older kids kept looking at us and
saying we're never going into debt after
this
after this conversation i'm not doing
that
i love it that's fabulous you guys well
done i love it wow how's it feel now
that you're free
it's unbelievable i can't it's so it's
still surreal
surreal we actually we finished baby
step two and now we've actually finished
baby step three and it's still
just the amount of focus that we have as
a family
and our dreams are right in front of us
and it's just so exciting so
i mean we can't thank you enough dave
with your program we were able to just
change our lives so thank you so much
and it's bled into so many other things
like it's
financial freedom but along the way we
learned how to communicate effectively
as a couple we learned about money
management putting every dollar with its
name i mean
we you have to do the envelope system to
be successful and then we merged over
to every dollar app and that was amazing
to guide our conversations
on saturday mornings and so when we just
got into that i mean i really feel
now it's trickled into our planning
processes at work like just
having the discipline to go through the
program
we called you uncle dave all the time
we'd be like well what would uncle dave
say about this yeah he wouldn't agree so
we're not doing that
and it really has it has honestly
changed our lives so other than the hard
arguments
that you all had every saturday morning
what would you say was one of the most
difficult things throughout this journey
for me it was the single focus like the
single task
focus so when the process tells you
you need to stop investing you need to
do things that may not make sense to you
but make sense to the plan and so
focusing on
the single task accomplishments and
making sure that
it makes sense to dave and nonsense to
you was really the
the thing that i learned because you
know i got myself into this mess
and i need i needed somebody else we
needed somebody else to get us
out so that was the big revelation i
think for me i think the biggest thing
too is finding that our value isn't in
the stuff that we buy
our value is not placed in that so
why were we buying things like what were
we
searching out and running down a rabbit
hole and just continually
purchasing things for no reason because
that's not where our value lies and so
we learned that we also learned that
john loves to spend
and he's rained that
what we're ultimately excited about is
being incredibly
generous because we have freed up funds
where we can now
start being incredibly generous now you
all have four kids i'm seeing here on
the screen it
looks like a beautiful family i'm
curious throughout this process
how was that relationship or how was uh
your kids involvement in this process i
know you said that they they want to
avoid debt
but how did you all incorporate them as
parents
educating them along this journey yes it
was really
great because they were part of the
envelope system with us
so they would see me pull out that cash
i would put the envelopes in with them
they would go to the grocery store
older kids would um i'd send them in for
groceries and they'd have to take
envelopes with them
and then even with our older daughter
she is 17 she's a senior in high school
and
we talked about emergency funds she has
a great job
that she has a little sidekick on the
side and she's
putting money aside and has an emergency
fund and her car broke down and guess
what
she had money in her emergency fund wow
and kind of full circle
she is back in school and um she's in a
financial peace class
lessons in personal finance yes her
curriculum is cool and so she's been
able to give
tips to her class and to her teacher
yeah for real
really funny but you know the other
thing is the kids have a long commute to
school and so before our daughter was
driving
john would drive him 35 minutes to
school and they would listen to your
show dave
and the kids the kids would start you
know at first they were rolling their
eyes don't take offense to that because
they're teenagers
but then they started reciting things
about what uncle dave would do well mom
you wouldn't believe
what these people were doing on dave's
show today and it was hilarious
wow because you know we're practicing
what we're show you know what we're
doing
you guys have truly changed your family
tree absolutely you didn't just pay off
some debt you changed everything
way to go so proud of you guys well done
well done okay one more time
what's the key to getting out of debt
you said submit to the plan right
you have to i would say the key to
getting out of debt is putting all the
guns at one target
you know getting through those stages
focusing on the task in front of you
you can't accomplish with baby step
three until you get to two
and now we're on three b and we're not
going to try to move to four until we
get accomplished with 3b yeah
stay the course yeah all the guns on one
target that's a good that's a good line
i like that
well done until until that one falls you
just keep shooting at that one target
exactly um it is there there's a reason
for that and it works
and it gets you momentum and uh the
emotions that are required to go through
30 minutes 30 months of deep sacrifice
like you all have been through
it's the only way you can fight through
it so way to go guys
way to go we got a copy of rachel cruz's
latest bestseller know yourself know
your money i think you guys will enjoy
it
it is uh it is done very well at the new
york times and so uh we'll send that to
you as
our gift so you got the whole gang there
to do the debt-free scream
they're still they're they're in
practice right now so they're not here
with us
we couldn't bring everybody together but
it's so it's just us but we're excited
to do it
and you wouldn't have heard anything we
have three-year-old twins dave come on
i love it yeah we never got through the
conversation
all right john and ashley grand rapids
michigan 63 thousand 000
paid off in 30 months making 90 to 105.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
you know what dave as endorsed by uncle
dave i'm trying to tell you but one of
the things he said that i love that i i
got to use this
in the future i'ma steal it from him it
may not make sense to you
but does it make sense to the plan yeah
that is like i hope america my best
thinking got me here
so i need some new thinking yes sir
that's you know
that's it if your best thinking got you
into a mess you need some new thinking
come on
you need something else to align
yourself to and go okay i gotta try
something i gotta do a different thing
over here
yes sir and uh a friend of mine said i
he said you know
i i couldn't get your stuff to work
until i submitted
yeah to the plan submission is a dirty
word in our culture nobody wants to
submit to anything
wow this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture of the day colossians 3 23
whatever you do
work at it with all your heart as
working for the lord not for human
masters
vince lombardi said it is time for us
all to stand and cheer for the doer
the achiever the one who recognizes the
challenges
and does something about it amen
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five anthony o'neil
ramsey personality is my co-host today
best-selling author as well and brian is
with jesus
brian is with us in asheville north
carolina hey brian how are you
it's doing well dave ayo how are you
guys doing better than i deserve how can
we help
uh so my wife and i are on baby steps
456
and we've recently been reviewing the
retirement investing plans um i have a
401k
a rough 401k for my employer and my wife
has a
403 b through her employer but that fees
into an annuity
and i was saying how you would recommend
us to allocate the 15
of our retirement income okay
well by and large you know the rock
paper scissors thing we're going to take
the match
first then we're going to do roth and
once we've filled up all roth and match
then we will go to the third one because
raw
match beats roth beats traditional and
so do you have a match on your 401k
yes i get a three and a half percent
match on my 401k
and my wife's match is a little tricky
that they automatically contribute
five percent even if she doesn't
contribute anything
and then they'll match up to two percent
after that so
if she puts in two percent she'll they
match seven okay
wow well i would put in her two even
though the investment's lousy
because you're getting 100 return on
investment before you start
yep right okay so i put in her two and
your three and a half
whatever past that then i'm going to
fund it all over in your 401k
because you can get into good mutual
funds and it's roth
past that i would do individual roths
yes we are we're maxing out our raw for
our roth iras right now
both of them and you're maxed out your
401k
uh no i'm currently putting in 10 um
she's putting in 10 percent in her 403
yeah i would not put 10 in hers because
she's stuck in that stupid new annuity
yeah
right i did recently switch it over to a
variable annuity
that's better if that's available yeah
you can get into some mutual funds that
way
that's going to be okay you could be
okay some of the variable annuities are
okay
have you got good mutual have you got
good mutual fund options inside of that
um they're not great they're not as good
as the ones that we have
through my 401k or our iras but you know
it's better than the six and three yeah
okay so here's the way i'd work the math
what is your household income uh 170
okay 15 of that
in a dollar figure okay take out
then you're a three and a half percent
match from that her two percent match
from that
then i would take out the individual
roth iras from that
and then i would put fill up your 401k
because you got better mutual fund
options than she does right
right if all of that does not get you up
to that fifteen percent number
which is going to be what twenty seven
thousand dollars or something right
yeah twenty six ways having enough range
somewhere right in there
if all of that doesn't get you up to
that number then put some into that
variable annuity above
the two percent where you're going for
the match but the weak sister in the
discussion is the variable annuity even
though it's not super bad
okay great is that is that right am i
missing something
no no that's right um we were just
wanting to make sure that you know
i didn't we didn't realize it was an
annuity at first when it all got set up
and then when we you know went through
to
reevaluate our investment strategy we
noticed that it was an annuity
and i didn't know much about it and then
i did some research and figured out they
were
they weren't that great no no that's the
problem with the 403 bs
a lot of the teachers situations the
insurance companies have gotten in
instead of the investment companies
and and so the investment quality of is
is just horrible
but the difference maker can be a good
variable annuity
at least that way you're getting to some
mutual funds because you're going to
make two
three times the rate of return on that
that you would have on that fixed
annuity
okay great but still it's still it's
still out of everything you got some
really good options available to you
and if they're all in high performing
good growth stock mutual funds the mix
like we're talking about and you're
taking all these matches
um and you you know the last thing i
would get to would be that variable
annuity yeah
but i think i think you i don't think
you're going to need it i think you can
get to 26 27 thousand dollars what we're
talking about here
by uh depending on how your incomes are
allocated but there's nothing
uh that says legally morally
relationally that you have to put the
same amount in hers as yours
right you can fill yours up and not put
any in hers because she's gonna get it
all
that's how that works yeah it's all hers
anyway who's got your name on it
now legally if there were a divorce or
something you've got access to each
other's
retirement plans and so lots of people
do
have to do all kinds of stuff with those
in the event of that or in the event of
death obviously you put the
spouse down as your beneficiary so it
doesn't matter where it's parked all
that matters is
in terms of that kind of stuff what
matters is which area performs the best
where are you going to get the best
mutual funds
so um yeah again rock paper scissors
matches first roth is next
to that tradition and then after that
traditional and anywhere along the way
you're looking for quality
options with the investment the mutual
fund and
uh you know the mutual funds that are
available to you yeah and the ones
available through that variable annuity
he was saying in that case
were not that great there are variable
annuities that have good mutual funds
absolutely they're out there but that's
still a second choice yeah now let me
ask you this dave i know some people are
probably thinking well dave they're
matching
seven percent because they've no it's
not sent in it's three and a half of his
right two of hers right not of 170
exactly
yeah gotcha and so that's why you have
to back in if you use the hard dollars
the real dollar amount yes
that'll get you there yeah and so you
say we're going to make up that number
we called it 27 thousand dollars okay
right and you say okay three and a half
percent of his income
let's say he made a hundred thousand
right right of their 170 right okay
then that's gonna be thirty five hundred
dollars out of the twenty seven thousand
then two percent of her income if she's
making 70 out of 170
then that's gonna be another fourteen
hundred dollars yes sir okay so
following
and we're working our way off at 27. yes
and then we go look at his ira
or his 401k and go what's the max i can
or we do the two roth iras six thousand
each that's another twelve thousand off
that
yes uh 27 000. so now we're getting down
to
uh the rest of it going over into this
401k can he
get the rest of it covered there if it
spills over one more time
if the every time these buckets spill
over right yes yes so you've you spilled
over
from the match now you spilled over from
the roths now you spill over from the
roth 401k
and the last spillover is going to be
over into that variable annuity if there
is any i think it's
i don't think in their particular but if
they made 200 000 they would have some
of that variable absolutely
they'd be up there because you're you
wouldn't have used up your 30 000
because that'd be 15 to 200 000 yes sir
so you wouldn't have gotten there but
that's how you back into if you use the
real dollar amount
rather than trying to figure out the
percentages because the potentials drive
driving nuts
really well because you've got to use
your household income
yeah you want to get 15 of your
household income
and when there's two different incomes
you're back and forth by it'll you know
i drive you nuts trying to calculate it
really well it's really easy just to
make it sixth grade math and start
taking chunks off
until you get down there that that lines
it up a lot a lot faster
yeah so here's the deal when a company
matches you put in
3 500 and they put in 3 500
even if the investment isn't great you
still made a hundred percent of your
money yeah
that's why matches first absolutely even
with her two percent
and the lesser thing yeah and then
tax-free
is better than no taxes until you take
it out which is tax deferred
yes but you're gonna pay taxes so you
got a million dollars tax free
or a million dollars taxable yeah that's
a three hundred thousand
five hundred thousand dollar swing
depending on who's in office and what
the tax law is
in terms of how much you end up with it
with your nest egg after taxes
yeah your after tax efficiency and so
match is first use that up spill over
to roth use that up spill over to
traditional
as your last and if you can't get it all
done with all those then you've got to
do something else like low turnover
mutual funds
yes sir so you can get there absolutely
get there good hour anthony hey thank
you dave
good job james childs kelly daniel in
the booth i am dave ramsey your host we
will be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section
or head over to daveramsey.com and click
dave recommends
thanks for listening
you